uh let's see what else we have going on
here because we are taking calls let's
go next to
uh Chang from Taiwan Chang welcome
uh hello can you hear me just just
barely barely barely uh I'll try to
speak up uh okay well I wanted to talk
about today was let's have a question
what kind of just exasperation but the
Republicans and the logic they apply to
gun regulation is just ridiculous
because they never seem to apply it to
just about anything else imagine if the
logic that they applied to guns was
applied to abortions you know if people
want this if they're determined to get
this they're going to get it somehow but
they don't seem to have be able to see
how their own logic can apply to other
situations scenarios and perhaps the
issue with that particular example is
that it can also be reversed on the left
by saying hey if your argument is that
by Banning abortions you don't actually
stop them then why do you think banning
guns will work you're right so that one
can be turned around on anybody
true but further left that would be more
the case that even if it's not a 100
prevention it's still a decrease which
is what you actually want
well they could say that about abortion
they could say yes some people will go
and have an unsafe home abortion but it
will be a decrease I mean they can
literally use the exact same phraseology
you are right from that it's it's just
very frustrating especially it's
frustrating I don't deny that there is a
double standard stuff recently as well
right right well it's a good point
although I think that they always have a
Counterpoint to it
yeah and unfortunately they don't
necessarily need their cancer points to
be consistent no they don't I mean the
right doesn't care about consistency
unfortunately yeah
uh thanks for taking my call all right
Chang thank you very much uh very
soft-spoken with a with a quiet
connection made it a little difficult
but we did it we really did